Speaker 1: Well, the first 24 hours of the
children's book have been insane. It is the number
one bestseller in its category on Amazon. This is
crazy. I don't even understand what's happening,
but I'll try to explain it to you. I wrote
a kid's book. Okay, here is the book. Think
like a detective. It's just a fun book
to start introducing critical thinking
concepts to kids. What is evidence? How do we
know that something's true? This sort of thing.
There's jokes in it that are more for adults
as well. You will see that there is a boy named
Ronald. There's a boy named Ronald on one page who
looks a lot like a particularly terrible former
president. And Ronald lied about the number of
kids at his birthday party. You get the joke. You
get it. We started making this available yesterday
on Amazon paperback and then Kindle preorders. All
the Kindle ones will come out on Saturday. It's
just the way it works. I had absolutely no idea
the way that this was going to go. And from the
number of complaints I received about the book,
you would think that it would go terribly. For
example, someone wrote to me and said, David,
this is too advanced for young kids. It's really
more for high school students. I don't think so.
It really is a kid's book. Yes, if you're six
or seven, you're going to need to have your, you
know, adult or guardian or someone read the book
to you. I get that and explain it. But this is not
a book for high schoolers. No, this is this is a
book for kids. But someone said, David, this is
too advanced. Someone wrote to me and said, David,
the picture of the kid detective on the front. The
kid should be a minority. It looks like the kid is
white, so I'm not going to buy the book. Oh, boy.
David The book should not be sold by Amazon. It
should be sold by someone else. I get the Amazon
stuff. Okay? The reality is that we're not looking
to buy a thousand of these and then ship them
out ourselves. Amazon's print on demand is really
convenient. Our main thing is this show. We needed
convenience. Okay, but I'm with you. Someone else
said, David, this book is not accessible globally
because it is only in English. That's true. We
only wrote the book in English. I'm sorry. Someone
else wrote it and said, David, the book should not
have been done with AI illustrations, even if we
did use illustrations as a base and then edit them
ourselves. That was wrong. Someone else wrote to
me said, David, you shouldn't have the Kindle
available for preorder. It should be available
now, like the paperback. It wasn't our choice. The
Amazon system requires some lead time before the
Kindle orders are filled. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
But we have persevered and this is insane. The
book is the number one bestseller in Amazon's
Children's reference and nonfiction section.
It is absolutely stunning to me. We have
four I don't know how many paperbacks have
been ordered. I only know how many have
been shipped. 108 paperbacks have already
been shipped and many more have been ordered.
232 people have preordered the digital Kindle
version. We have received orders from the
U.K., Germany, Italy, Australia, Canada.
It's it's just incredible. It's incredible.
That all being said, I do want to go through
and just show you some amazing messages and
reviews that we got. Braden wrote in with a
really good idea and said, Potential tribute
children's book band David huge fan of the new
children's book. I think it's a great idea.
I plan on buying it. However. How long do you
think it will take for Florida to ban it for woke
indoctrination? I'd love to hear your thoughts,
my friends. I hope someone tries to ban this book.
People have been writing to me saying they're
going to gift the book to a bunch of libraries. I
hope a library rejects it. I hope someone I have
teachers writing to me saying, David, I'm going
to use this book in class. I going to read this
book to my students. The book is not political.
Yes, it makes fun of Trump book, but it's not a
political book. Little kids wouldn't even realize
that. It's like an adult joke. I would love it.
If parents go crazy because their teacher read
this book to students in class, I would love it
if a school librarian. Who the hell knows?
Tennessee tries to ban the book. I hope
they try to ban the book. Let's try to make it
happen. I think it would be a great story. Okay,
Now some really great reviews already on Amazon.
And please remember, if you order the book,
please review it. It's so important. It's the
number one thing that determines how it will do.
Okay, x, here's one review. Excellent secular
homeschooling resource. I homeschool my learning
disabled son and I'm excited for this book.
All students should learn how to think. I can't
wait for the author to publish books about this
subject for teens and adults. Beautiful review.
Next review will bring tears to your eyes.
I see what you did there. Wonderful book for
our future leaders. Save the Country. Have your
children learn about critical thinking at ASAP.
Sir, I write this as a big, strong man. I have
tears in my eyes with the thought of giving this
book to my children. Beautiful, beautiful message.
Folks, I don't know how far this is going to go.
It really started kind of as a goof, but it's now
the best seller in its category on Amazon. You can
get it on Kindle, you can get it on paperback, buy
copies, distribute them to libraries, give them to
your kids. Teachers say, here's something to read
David Pacman dot com slash book. Let's keep going
as we push this into more countries and please
review the book. Let me know what you think, etc..